الرشاقه او التسريح بهذه الكلمات انشغل
العراقيون خلال الساعات الماضيه بعد تداول
وثيقه على مواقع التواصل قيل انها صادره
عن وزاره الدفاع العراقيه
[موسيقى]
فقد نقلت الوثيقه تعليمات جديده تجيز
احاله الضباط الذين يعانون من السنه
وزياده الوزن الى التقاعد في حال عجزهم عن
ترشيق اوزانهم
كما طالبت الجميع بالالتزام باللياقه
البدنيه مشدده على ان المترهلين منهم سيتم
احالتهم للتقاعد
كده عليك ذكر ان الوثيقه التي وجهت الى
المديريات والقطاعات تحوي على توجها من
قائد القوات البريه باجراء الضباط
المترهلين برتبه ملازم نقيب فحصا للوزن
مشدده على ان من لا يستطيع تخفيض وزنه
سيحال للتقاعد
لكن رغم كل هذه الضجه لم تنشر الوزاره اي
تعليق الرسمي حول الموضوع على حساباته
الرسميه كما لم تاكد صحه الوثيقه او
التوجيهات لا من قريب او بعيد في حين
انقسمت الاراء بين مؤيدا ومعارض وبعضها
سخر على اعتبار ان وزاره الدفاع تكره
الاوزان الزائده في حين اي ده البعض
القرار الاعتبارات العسكريه وعمليه
الى ذلك البعض ايضا ان في الوثيقه ان صحت
فعلا تشكل نوعا من التنمر غير المقبول ممن
يعانون السمنه خصوصا مع قرار استبعادهم
[موسيقى]